travis is with us in buffalo hi travis
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi dr john how are you guys
doing
great how can we help okay so
well me and my girlfriend have been
going out for
two and a half years and we're living
together
and well when it comes to money
we're kind of she kind of does
her thing and i kind of do my thing
on like i follow you guys on your steps
and everything
and like my question is
like how do i
like not get her like to tell her to
come on jump on board
but like to understand like
what i'm doing what are you doing
um i'm pretty much i'm on baby step
number two
i'm no i wasn't i was i was being a
little bit facetious
like
what's your what's your future with this
with this woman
um like i planned on marrying her in the
next
probably cup a year
or so does she plan on being married to
you back
um we have talked about it i mean
that is definitely one of our futures
goals
like we also talked about kids and all
that
so like we do plan on having a future
together and all that and
and it's like to keep with my steps and
everything else like that i want her to
understand
like how i deal with that
so does she not like it or she doesn't
agree with it
um like she kind of does her own
way of things like like if she needs
something she'll go get it herself
and like i've kind of been
like on the front of i don't know
exactly if we should start working
together or
as like a team before marriage
like combining income and all that
or anything like that
how old are you i'm 25. how old is she
she's 25 as well okay all right the
problem you're having is
it's hard to be sort of married
yeah it's like being sort of pregnant
and and you're trying to act like you're
married in some ways and not act like
you're married in other ways and it's
not working
because it doesn't work and so we see
this all the time in couples that are
shacked up they have a very very
difficult time
because it's it's it's legally and
relationally
uh unwise for you to combine everything
but and yet you're trying to act like
you're married which would indicate that
you would combine everything
and so i don't really know how to advise
you well
on this yeah um you know unless you
just decided okay we're going to live in
two separate places
and date and we're going to
start talking about the value systems
that we have
about saving money about spending money
about debt
about our future and what it would look
like if we were to combine our
households and if we were to get married
how are we going to make them one and on
the same page
and you can try that while you're living
together but it's going to be very
difficult
as you've already discovered and so um
you know i think you can you know that's
probably the first step actually is you
say
look we cannot operate our lives
for 40 years 50 years going forward the
way they're operating now
on two separate pages on two separate
planes this is not a recipe for success
we if we're going to have a future
together we're going to have to start
figuring out how we're going to put our
life together and what it's going to
look like
and the wedding ceremony is not the the
joining it up
it's the life that you build intertwined
with one another
yeah that makes sense yeah in other
words you don't have to convince her of
anything
except that that not being on the same
page is a deal breaker
because dude it's a deal breaker it's
the number one cause of divorce
yeah like for me it was just
i felt like
like i'm not meaning as in like joint
income it was like because
i was in like for me it was i was
spending
so much because we did the separation
for a while
and made that try to make it work but
then i was like for me i was financially
spending too much on travel and
food expenses and stuff like that yeah
you're
you're missing what we're saying you're
you're trying to make this a math
problem brother and this is not a math
problem
this is a unity problem yeah this is the
two of you don't see the future the same
correct and therefore the future is not
going to be together
until you can see the future the same
and so
we need to have a conversation it sounds
like um
if we're going to move forward in this
relationship and move towards marriage
then we're going to have to start
talking about the four
things that affect marriages money
religion in-laws and kids and if you can
be in agreement on those four things
in your pre-marriage state in
pre-marriage counseling engagement
period
those kinds of things you can come into
agreement how you don't have to have
kids but you just got to say
i don't want six kids well i want ten
well we got a problem
uh i think kids ought to be able to make
up all their own decisions from the time
they're three owned
i don't i think they ought to do what i
say well that's going to be a problem
i think my mother ought to be able to
come over here and tell us what to do
well i think that's a problem in-laws
kids
problems money i think ought to be able
to spend whatever i want to spend no
matter what as long as i make money
it'll be my money and you make money and
you take care of the rest of the house
well i don't think that's how we're
going to do it
problem so you need to be in agreement
on
religion i don't think there's a god i'm
sure there's a god and i think people
that don't think there's a god's an
idiot well then that's a problem
and so you know you need to be in
agreement on marriage
money in-laws and kids and your
pre-marriage state
otherwise you don't have a candidate for
marriage
you've had a fun roommate and a maybe a
good compadre for the last two years
but you don't have someone to build an
entire future with together
i think i think you've got to go sit
down and say where do we want this thing
if it worked out perfectly
what would we want this to look like and
reverse engineer it
right now it sounds like rather you are
just stumbling and tripping
and uh i think i'll do this and i think
we're gonna do this but i'd like to do
that
even your verbal pattern is very
uncertain travis yeah
it's like you you have no certainty
about where you're headed
and so you need to sit down and go we're
gonna if we're gonna move forward in
this
or you could just languish in this you
can choose that but you're you're asking
us how to get you know get on the same
page and it's
lay out what the page looks like on all
of these things and go
you know we need to start talking
through these things if we're gonna move
forward it's not just can we share the
mustard
it's gonna be on my t-shirt yeah
marriage can we share them can we share
the mustard
because you know if you got two things
of mustard that's what you have with a
roommate
you got two mustard that's my mustard
your mustard yes it right there in the
door of the refrigerator don't touch my
mouth
i gotta remember cause sharpie yeah
dave's mustard don't mess with dave's
mustard
hey so i i know you should probably be
asking me me this question but
you've done this for way longer than me
so i
i came into marriage almost two decades
ago
with a very clear list of the things i
wanted values i thought were were deal
breakers for me things that were i was
really firm on
here's what i think about kids and
probably the most recurring theme over
the last two decades is
i was wrong right i thought i wanted
this many kids and i thought
as long as you're in agreement that's
okay all along i don't care
that we're going to so you could get
married saying i want 10 kids and five
years later the two of you have traveled
the world you go
i think the two of us are looking at
each other going we want a chihuahua or
you have kid one and you're like
i'm out i'm out tap out that one right
there that did it
that's the second one that did it for
sure we're gonna make these decisions
together
yeah not hours in yours and mine it's
not not
you know but you can't come in and go
you know you get married going i want 10
kids and then you go i change my mind
unilaterally without discussion with the
other friends that's not a showdown
that's right